alors on parle d'abord des impôts est
d'abord de ce diagnostic donc dressé
tardivement pense qu ont certains par le
premier ministre les français en la
matière ont atteint la tolérance zéro
les impôts seront donc sans doute un
marqueur de ce quinquennat comme l'avait
été la courbe du chômage pour françois
hollande
mais cette baisse de la pression fiscale
qui doit elle concerner en priorité là
les désaccords se manifeste y compris au
sein de la majorité on en parle mais
d'abord un petit retour en arrière
cette et en 2013 après un an de
quinquennat hollande très sensible à ce
ras le bol fiscal que je ressens de la
part de nos concitoyens qu'ils soient
des ménages des consommateurs où qu'ils
soient des entreprises et ça nous
l'écoutons c'est la raison pour laquelle
je le répète dans le redressement
nécessaire nous inverserons les
proportions par rapport à 2013 entre les
économies qu'ils doivent être
prioritaires et les prélèvements
obligatoires qui doit être aussi peu
important aussi faible que possible pour
l'ange pit à 1013 2010 9,6 en fait qu'un
ce pays est abonné à deux choses quand
la droite arrive au pouvoir elle baisse
les impôts quand la gauche arrive au
pouvoir
elle augmente les dépenses publiques
mais quand la droite est au pouvoir elle
ne baisse pas les dépenses publiques
et quand la gauche est arrivée au
pouvoir elle maintient elle elle
maintient les impôts donc on est dans la
droite à la face à ce vide en moi je
suis je suis je dois dire vous je suis
pas très représentatif de la majorité ni
du modem ni deux ni d'un république en
marché parce que tout ce qui se passe
depuis trois mois
mon surmoi de vieux techno rationaliste
souffre ce que je ne comprends pas
comment on peut aborder des problèmes
budgétaires dans cette confusion on
demande aux gens s'ils veulent que les
impôts baisse qu'est ce que vous voulez
qu'ils vous disent oui sauf les impôts
qui sont payés clairement par les autres
comme il est c'est fait vous demander
aux gens s'ils les dépenses publiques
doivent baisser
il se dit il flaire l'arna qui se disent
ou là ça va me concerne et ça donc ils
disent
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire en
réalité je moi je crois pour l'économie
je ne sais pas si l économie de l'offre
mais je crois à la politique de l'offre
je crois que notre système fiscal est
assez profondément est d'ailleurs très
profondément redistributeur d'ores et
déjà je ne crois pas que ce soit là
qu'ils soient malades il est sans doute
très faible nous n'avons plus de
fiscalité locale prat et avec la
disparition la taxe d'habitation
nous n'avons plus de fiscalité locale
nous avons encore une fiscalité abusifs
sur la production c'est à dire ça sur
les entreprises ça les gens n'aiment pas
qu'on le dise il faudrait pourtant si si
et il faudrait et quant aux dépenses
publiques il ya aucun consensus sinon un
consensus totalement mythologique sur
les dépenses qu'on devrait baisser au il
faut faire baisser les dépenses de
l'état évidemment l'armée parce que
l'armée où on va papa lé là qui sait
c'est pas c'est pas ainsi qu'on pourra
vraiment avancer il faut avoir un
programme cohérent sur plusieurs années
de réorganisation de notre si qualité et
de de modération de la dépense publique
mais là je suis un peu seul albi alexis
c'est vrai que cette prise de conscience
tout le monde l'a souligné hier la les
propos du premier ministre qui va sans
doute répéter à l'assemblée ça fait un
petit peu on enfonce une porte ouverte
c'est déjà faux l'enfoncer non parce que
c'est des chaires quelque chose de le
gros ca
on n'est pas obligé d'avant la crise et
gilet jaune et le grand débat et on
parle et on parle on parle pour ça pour
te rendre compte les trop d'impôts dans
ce pays m'enfin bon il ne finisse pour
le découvrir tant mieux c'est formidable
maintenant donné qu'on valait bck une
immense exaspération fiscales ont
franchi chaque fois un degré parce que
c'est plus que le ras-le-bol fiscal le
choix des mots importants immense
exaspération fiscale formidable un
iphone de dire quels impôts a baissé
quand comment et quels économie on va
faire en face et là je rejoins jean
louis bourlanges parce que on peut pas
baisser durablement les impôts si on
fait pas d'économies
donc il faut faire les deux et on peut
faire les deux camps quand vont-ils s'en
donner les moyens politiques mais
évidemment qu'on peut baisser les impôts
évidemment qu'on peut faire des
économies et la vraie la vraie marge de
manoeuvre pour les économies et
d'ailleurs on voit bien que les
ministres qui poutre et baisses d'impôts
pousse aussi cette marge de manoeuve là
au grand déplaisir de la gauche ou la
j'anticipe un peu c'est la question de
la durée du travail sur la vie il faut
la grande source de d'économiser sur les
dépenses sociales et attire des parts
sociales des dépenses de retraite et le
moyen d'économiser sur les dépenses de
retraite s'est forgé alors on va en
parler avec vous deux est également
juste pour ce qui est de qui doit être
concerné par ces baisses d'impôts on va
entendre deux points de vue différents
d'abord celui de bruno le maire qui
s'exprimait ce matin sur france info sur
la question l'écoutent à mes yeux la
cohérence entre politique fiscale et
politique économique pourrait nous
amener à baisser en priorité l'impôt sur
le revenu c'est à dire l'impôt de
cheveux qui travaillent la rémunération
de ceux qui travaillent en commençant
par ceux qui ont les niveaux de revenus
les plus modestes qui rentre dans
l'impôt sur le revenu et qui rend de
manière plus brutale et c'est l'impôt
des revenus les plus modestes c'est
insuffisant répond laurent wauquiez
public qu'on écoute également pourquoi
est ce que je veux que ce soit une
baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu pour
tous parce que les principales victimes
de l'impôt sur le revenu c'est les
classes moyennes le gouvernement agite
et une proposition consistant à dire on
va baisser l'impôt sur le revenu mais
seulement pour les plus modestes
ben moi je considère qu'il faut arrêter
d'oublier systématiquement ceux qui sont
au milieu
la guerre entre les deux il ya plusieurs
questions
il ya donc sérieusement il ya deux
questions il y as qu'on paye trop
d'impôts ou pas qui justifierait les
ventes à lui usage de l'expression
exaspération fiscal alors les esprits
ont été préparés on nous explique depuis
très longtemps que évidemment on paye
trop d'impôts et pour preuve d'ailleurs
on est devenus les champions du monde
des prélèvements obligatoires
oui mais c'est pas parce qu'on paye plus
d'impôts que les autres qu'on en paye
trop où tout s'était pas accès comme
indice par besoin tous les autres en
paix passés non elle est seule en place
et le monde entier fait passer devant au
pardonnez moi je vais au bout de ma
phrase on peut dire qu'on est les
champions du monde des prélèvements
obligatoires on peut aussi expliquer
pourquoi nous le sommes et pourquoi nous
avons fait le choix de lettres on a pas
si longtemps les français pour une
raison précédents dirigeants ont fait le
choix maintenant c'est au pas fait ce
jour n'ont jamais gens
non ce qui nous distingue par rapport
aux autres et ce qui justifie ce qui
nous distingue donc alors on laisse
terminer mathieu sait flairer band est
un produit français le plus primitif
distingue absolument ce qui nous
distingue des autres et qu'ils
justifient ce niveau de prélèvements
obligatoires supérieur aux autres
c'est notre protection sociale notre
protection sociale a nou lé dit
universel c'est à dire que l'hôpital
comme l'école profite autant aux riches
qu'aux pauvres dans la plupart des
autres pays développés
si on paye moins d'impôts c'est parce
qu'on ne finance pas la protection
sociale des riches comme on le fait chez
nous ici l'hôpital public qui est
d'excellente qualité
on a accès gratuitement aux meilleurs
spécialistes de la médecine mondiale
parce que les médecins français sont
parmi les meilleurs au monde qu'on soit
riche ou pour soi pauvre gratuitement et
c'est cette protection sociale universel
qui coûte très cher l'aveu ton-là
refuse-t-on encore une fois on sait que
l'évolution de la vie en société
aujourd'hui c'est des gens qui vivent
plus longtemps des malades à soigner des
gens qui parfois sont au chômage est la
résultante de cette politique sociale là
c'est en france au moins alors même que
nous avons une dynamique inégalitaire
partout dans le monde des inégalités qui
au moins chez nous son contenu alors
c'est pas totalement absurde on est le
pays qui inscrit l'égalité dans sa dans
sa devise républicaine mais chez nous
précisément le pacte social qui a encore
grâce à cette protection sociale
universel revient tout petit peu narnia
de gnac
alexis nous disait ça jamais été
véritablement le choix des français
plutôt de leurs gouvernants bon oui
frais des français et à partir de partir
des sommes du programme du conseil de la
libération de la résistance excusez moi
du ccnr bon on s'achemine vers un état
providence on n'est pas les seuls
d'ailleurs à peu près tout toutes les
sociétés capitalistes ce qu'on appelait
le capitalisme rhénan soient orientés et
on observe que les français sont très
attachés
l'idée
il comprit abusivement je pense au tiers
payant se sont réveillés à lattes
l'idée d'une totale gratuité des soins y
compris les soins dont ils n'ont pas
besoin d'ailleurs parce qu'on a vu que
le courage de schröder qui en allemagne
fait une réforme de la santé et des
draps sticks sont pas plus malades
qu'avant donc
donc oui c'est quand même bon on est en
train on est en train de prendre
conscience que l'état providence dans la
plus les moyens ou alors on le fait
payer sur le dos de nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants
moi j'y suis assez attaché je le trouve
un bon bon bon bon bon vieux gaulliste
s'est attaché mais il faut pour le moins
le repenser de fond en comble parce que
sinon je vous dis on va on va on va
perdre ce qui nous reste de
compétitivité on alourdit c'est jean
louis borloo lange avait raison la
vienne une fiscalité des entreprises qui
étaient accessibles
il y à une fiscalité et comment
dirais-je oui non il faut il faut il
faut penser de tout cela pour faire des
coupes sombres ya pas seulement dans le
domaine social d'ailleurs faut regarder
du côté des collectivités d'alliot-marie
une question une question est de savoir
si on peut le financer
l'autre est de savoir comment on le
finance or pardon mais je rappelle aussi
une vérité d'évidence au cours de ces
dernières années on a fait des
transferts de charge d'abord des ménages
vers le pardon d'abord des entreprises
vers les ménages c'est-à-dire qu'on a
abaissé la fiscalité des entreprises de
façon massive et évidemment ce coup là
il a fallu le compenser en augmentant la
fiscalité sur les ménages et dans cette
fiscalité sur les ménages
ce qu'on a le plus augmenté c'est la
fiscalité pour la masse par ailleurs en
diminuant la fiscalité des ménages aisés
légendes urbaines acquis et le
merveilleux modèle social français que
le monde entier devait nommer c'est pas
des français y étaient attachés
mais c'est quoi ce modèle social
dépasser le modèle où il ya le plus de
chômage en europe
c est ce que c'est le modèle où les
l'ascenseur social est absolument blocus
est pas le cas ce qui coûte cher chez
nous leur part dans les sacs les
retraites est ce que les français sont
si les retraités louis tôt mais je ne
fais pas ça même en france on parle de
films et bien sûr
ces lignes et non parce que la somme des
dunes et dick nom donné par le régime
la somme des sommes engagées pour cette
protection sociale formidable pèsent sur
les entreprises et à la fal sont pas
compétitives et donc il ya du chômage
ça c'est un fait est ce que quand est-ce
que l'ascenseur social d'orzy c'est la
vocation sociale ne prend pas l'eau est
ce qui ne fonctionne très bien notre
système notre système éducatif est ce
qu'on nécessite beaucoup moins à
ministre mien vient d'enregistrer que
les allemands par exemple
non non il n'y a pas un français qu'il
pense donc on n'a jamais dit les choses
clairement français on leur a fait tout
un tas de promesses davantage 100 mètres
en face les coûts et aujourd'hui chaque
fois qu'on les interroge et qu'on met en
face les coûts et les avantages il dit
manon les impôts c'est trop cher pour ce
que ça nous rapporte alors terminé je
tenais pas à mêler les se plaisent au
début je voulais rappeler qu'à moitié
des français ne payent pas d'impôts il
va rappeler que c'est par là c'est pas
avec la révolte sociale ça soit revenu
ou sa palette la réforme sociale des
gilets jaunes part de gens qui sont
juste à la limite du smig qui commence à
payer
je sais quoi
oui les restitutions du grand débat a
montré qu' il y avait une très large
majorité qui se dégageait pour que tout
le monde paye je crois que ce grand
départ ailleurs que dans les allocations
et des consommations ce grand débat ne
pouvait pas par construction aboutir à
des décisions précises pointu moi je
crois c'est ce que j'aime bien dans le
livre de tavoillot se re qui peut
gouverner un peuple roi c'est que la
politique ça demande du boulot demande
d'étudier de se documenter et de savoir
ce qui va pas et ce qui va ce qui va pas
c'est pas trop ou pas assez d'impôts ce
qui ne va pas d'abord c'est je crois qu
alexis a raison c'est le problème de
l'imposition sur l'appareil de
production ça notamment les impôts de
production on est vraiment dans une
situation anormale par rapport à nos
concurrents allemands donc là il faut
baisser les impôts ça n'est pas
populaire il faut dire ça n'est pas
populaire parce que c'est pas bon de là
le deuxième le deuxième mythe comme oui
on le traite mais on était bien sûr mais
drame mon reste quand même et de façon
assez importante s'il fait plus la
seleçao bien marché en fait ce qu'a fait
aux gens sur le séisme et six pays
arrêtons d'avoir une vie
dion à court terme en dix ans que le cic
eux va immédiatement produire des
résultats en termes de chômage ce n'est
pas ça le problème c'est de savoir
qu'elle est là la pression fiscale
légitime sur les entreprises pour que ça
fonctionne et nous étions décrocher nous
sommes encore assez largement décroché
avec beaucoup trop d'impôts de
production le deuxième mythe c'est que
tout le monde ne payent pas d'impôts
parce que avec la saison le revenu sur
la norme et à la csg de la combinaison
l'impôt sur le revenu et la csg même si
ce sont deux deux prélèvements
différentes pas tout à fait de même
nature fait que en réalité on a un impôt
proportionnel assez massif avec la csg
et on a un impôt progressif avec l'impôt
sur le revenu ça se combinent
troisièmement c'est en matière de
prestations sociales
est-ce que nous sommes trop généreux ou
trop mal gérée sans doute un peu des
deux
la mauvaise gestion est évidente sur la
façon les intermittents du spectacle
c'est pas gérer de façon rigoureuse
c'est évident le ce que signale alexis
est très juste sur les retraites
nous sommes quand même dans un sur
l'indemnisation du chômage quand on
compare notre situation par rapport à
celle des allemands ou celle des
britanniques
on est très avantagés donc il ya
certainement quelque chose à revoir et
c'est les retraites
hélas les retraites on est très embêté
quand on est comme moi dans la majorité
parce qu'on est parti du mauvais pied si
je peux dire en disant on va pas toucher
à l'âge de la retraite est maintenant
donc delvoye travail dans un cadre est
maintenant à juste titre sur le plan
économique le premier ministre et
quelques ministres disent on ne peut pas
faire d'une baisse substantielle de la
dépense publique
si et maintenir un niveau de revenu à un
niveau de retraite élevé sans alourdir
les cotisations sur les actifs si on ne
repousse pas d'une manière ou d'une
autre par l'âge de la retraite le veut
voilà le problème de violence est pas
populaire tout 103 cas pour pauvres pour
baisser les impôts et faire décoller il
ya deux volants y a
la masse de la fonction publique les
fonctionnaires et ça le seul moyen de
diminuer leur nombre sans diminuer le
service rendu aux personnes c'est de
faire en sorte que les fonctionnaires
travaillent davantage qu'aujourd'hui on
l'a vu il ya encore eu un rapport qui
nous montrent qu'un tiers d'entre eux
travaillent moins de 35 heures donc il
faut que ça leur tombe dessus il faut
qu'il travaille davantage pour qu'on
puisse en avoir moins donc offrir le
même service fera strauss kahn arrivé à
plein temps 2-3 35 ça c'est le premier
moyen donc c'est la durée du travail
dans la dans l'année dans la semaine
dans la journée pour les fonctionnaires
et le deuxième moyen c'est la durée sur
rail pour tout le monde y compris les
fonctionnaires et pour eux c'est vrai
que c'est la double peine
sur l'ensemble de la vie ou au diamant
où la vie des plus en plus longues et on
entre sur le marché du travail de plus
en plus tard un petit nombre d'actifs de
plus en plus petits ne peut pas financer
un nombre des actifs de plus en plus
grand faim cc c'est mathématique c'est
d'une bêtise évident mais même sur ses
piges et que si on pourrait peut-être
sur le côté parce que finalement le
baby-boom arrivent à l'âge de la
retraite et ensuite il y aura de nouveau
un creux oui il nous quittera non mais
alors là je voulais juste répondre sur
le sur le poids de l'état écrasant et
c'est le le le poids de l'état en
pourcentage de pib il est constant en
fait depuis une trentaine d'années ça
pèse ça représente quasiment 20% du pib
le coût de fonctionnement de l'état et
ses constants en fait depuis 30 ans est
par ailleurs ça ne coûte pas plus cher
chez nous que y compris dans les pays
anglo saxons m'en fais poser en
angleterre mais le plus élevé du monde
la protection sociale c'est ce que je
vous disais il ya cinq minutes en fait
c'est la protection sociale qui fait la
différence c'est pas du tout le poids de
l'état répond de focaliser sur les
fonctionnaires ils seraient trop
nombreux et trop fainéant
c'est la règle du jeu vous la connaissez
votre avis d'abord la question le
gouvernement va-t-il parvenir à baisser
les impôts 30% pensent que oui donc une
large majorité
alors r34 no 10 est toujours la même
rengaine on parle des plus modestes mais
le gouvernement ne comprend pas que les
classes moyennes en ont ras-le-bol c'est
ce que disait nicolas définition n'est
jamais nicole on paye trop d'impôts et
le pire c'est qu'on ne voit pas où ils
passent vu l'état des services publics
si je vous dis je ne suis pas sûr que
l'allemagne soit un bon exemple avec
leur boulot ultra précaire et le
retraité qui ne peuvent pas vivre sans
continuer à bosser et à 34 qui revient
en 8 heures la moitié des français ne
payent pas l'impôt sur le revenu et
c'est un scandale ce que je vous disais
c'est une des ddd refais un des leur
restitution
je crois que c'est une des premières
choses qui arrivent en tête des jeux
dédiés aux que tout le monde paye
l'impôt non déclaratif ça existe la peau
sur le revenu il le déclarait t il le
déclare encore donc ils voient ce que
c'est la csg elle est prélevée
directement sur l'or sur leurs feuilles
de paye et ça il le voit pas tant que
c'est une émission de près c'est vrai
qu'il ya comme 10% des français qui pèse
70 % des revenus
donc c'est 10% là qui sont des très
méchants riches ça fait beaucoup quand
même donc évidemment ils se disent pas
pourquoi les autres pourquoi j'ai pas à
moi tout seul je pèse sont des
constantes impose aux questions que je
posais au début mais ça va être
effectivement le l'équivalent de la
courbe du chômage pour françois hollande
les impôts pour emmanuel macron
j'écoutais je sais je sais pas faire ce
parallèle la schizo jour c'est que
françois hollande avait payé très cher
en fait son pronostic
non je je suis pas sûr les premières
annonces quand même que macron a fait le
10 décembre
elles lui ont permis dans les sondages
clairement d'inverser les choses avec 10
milliards
il s'est remis en dynamique politique
alors je ne sais pas si en rajoutant
quelques milliards la semaine prochaine
la tendance va se poursuivre en
particulier au moment d'aider des
européennes mais on peut dire que à ce
stade même si les attentes sont fortes
et qu'un certain scepticisme s'exprime
autour de cette question du grand débat
et de ce qui va en sortir pour l'instant
macron n'a pas continué de dévisser
encore une fois il ya une inflexion à
cnet après les annonces qu'il a faites
le 10 décembre s'est demandé gentiment
j'arrive je crois que le problème de
hollande sait que la meilleure chose
qu'il a faite c'est le cic eux et c'est
ça qui la plombe qu'il a perdu
politiquement c'est dramatique quand
vous faites quelque chose de bien
vous êtes condamné pour ça c'est ce que
disait françois mauriac
et toujours condamné pour les cris prend
la parole